c'est devenu le quotidien de George
Santos pour chasser par une meute de
journaliste le nouvel élu républicain se
fait poser la même question va-t-il des
missionnaires c'est qu'à part son âge et
sa nationalité il aurait menti sur tout
ses études sa carrière et même sa
famille pour gravir les échelons du
Congrès
mon grand-père juif a fui du crâne en
1920 dit-il puis les nazis avant d'aller
au Brésil en 1940 et pourtant rien sur
sa famille dans les archives de
l'Holocauste ce qui sème la colère dans
la coalition juive républicaine dans son
CV il est fermé à avoir obtenu un
diplôme du Collège baroque de New York
qu'il était champion de volley-ball
qu'il a fréquenté l'Université de New
York les deux institutions n'ont aucune
trace de lui même scénario pour Goldman
Sachs
que j'ai embellie mon CV oui dit-il mais
bon ce n'est pas un crime ajoute-t-il
il devient alors la cible préférée des
humoristes
pourquoi le volley-ball se demande
bigmaire oh non mais cet ancien
combattant n'a pas envie de rire en 2016
Josh Santos l'aurait aidé à masser 3000
dollars pour sauver la vie de son chien
atteint de cancer
je lui ai donné mon numéro de compte
dit-il parce qu'il allait déposer
l'argent ce n'est jamais arrivé le chien
est mort quelque temps après sintos
rétorque qui compte me connaît c'est que
j'irai en enfer pour un chien qu'il
aille au diable dit-il et rien ne semble
sacré pour Jos Santos même la tragédie
du 11 septembre
je deviens émotive disait-il en 2020 mes
parents y étaient
ma mère était une survivante du 11
septembre
dans la tour sud mais elle s'en est
sorti or selon le département
d'immigration sa mère se trouvait au
Brésil à ce moment-là et n'avait pas mis
les pieds aux États-Unis depuis 1999
moi je m'arrête
ce premier répondant du 11 septembre à
New York 59% des résidents de longue
Island réclament cette émission
il devrait s'en débarrasser dit-il ici
les élus républicains même les plus
conservateurs réclament cette démission
le traite d'un poster d'hommes
malhonnête mais avec une majorité
seulement de 222 sièges à la Chambre des
Représentants plusieurs crèmes que le
parti ne peut se permettre de perdre un
seul siège
il est complètement fou dit-il
toute jauge Santos est membre de deux
comités la Chambre des Représentants
aujourd'hui les procureurs fédéraux
enquête sur les finances de sa campagne
électorale même les autorités
brésiliennes vont rouvrir une enquête de
2008 impliquant Santos et un chéquier
frauduleux
de New York
jamais sous celui de George Santos